18 minutos es absolutamente un límite de tiempo brutal,
de modo que me lanzaré directamente al punto
para lograr que esto salga bien.
Bueno. Hablaré de cinco cosas diferentes.
Voy a hablar de por qué vale la pena vencer el envejecimiento.
Voy a hablar de por qué tenemos que organizarnos,
y hablar de esto más a menudo de lo que lo hacemos.
Voy a hablar de factibilidad también, por supuesto.
Voy a hablar de por qué somos tan fatalistas
para hacer cualquier cosa acerca del envejecimiento.
Por lo tanto, voy a pasar tal vez la segunda mitad de la charla
hablando de cómo podemos probar que el fatalismo es un error,
en otras palabras, haciendo realmente algo al respecto.
Voy a hacerlo en dos etapas.
En la primera hablaré acerca de
cómo llegar desde una relativamente modesta extensión de vida...
que voy a definir como 30 años, aplicada a personas
que están ya en la mediana edad cuando empiezas...
hasta un punto que verdaderamente se puede llamar vencer al envejecimiento.
Es decir, fundamentalmente una eliminación de la relación entre
qué edad tienes, y qué probabilidades tienes de morir el próximo año...
o ciertamente , de enfermarte en un primer momento.
Y por supuesto, lo último que hablaré será de
cómo alcanzar la etapa intermedia,
ese punto de casi 30 años de vida.
Voy a empezar por el porqué deberiamos alcanzarlo.
Ahora ,quiero hacerles una pregunta.
Levanten la mano : ¿Alguien de aquí está a favor de la malaria?
Eso fue fácil. OK.
OK. Levanten la mano: ¿alguien de la audiencia
que no esté seguro si la malaria es algo bueno o malo?
OK. Entonces todos pensamos que la malaria es algo malo.
Eso es una muy buena noticia, ya que así pensé que sería la respuesta.
Ahora el asunto es, me gustaría plantearles
que la razón principal de por qué creemos que la malaria es algo malo
es porque una característica de la malaria se relaciona con el envejecimiento.
Y aquí está esa característica.
Lo único diferente es que envejecer mata más personas que la malaria.
Me gusta frente a una audiencia, en Gran Bretaña especialmente,
hablar de la comparación con la caza de zorros,
que fue prohibida después de una larga lucha,
por el gobierno hace unos pocos meses.
Quiero decir, sé que cuento hoy con un público comprensivo,
pero, como vemos, a muchas personas no les convence esta lógica.
Y esto me parece a mí una muy buena comparación.
Mucha gente dijo, "Bueno, ya sabes,
los urbanos no tienen por qué decirnos a los rurales qué hacer con nuestro tiempo.
Es una tradición en nuestra vida,
y deberían permitirnos continuar haciéndolo.
Es ecológicamente válido; detiene la explosión demográfica de los zorros".
Pero en última instancia, el gobierno se impuso al final,
porque la mayoría de los británicos,
y ciertamente la mayoría de los miembros del Parlamento,
llegaron a la conclusión que era algo realmente
que no se debía tolerar en una sociedad civilizada.
Y yo creo que el envejecimiento humano comparte
todas estas características sin lugar a dudas.
¿Qué parte de esto no entiende la gente?
No se trata sólo de la vida, por supuesto...
(Risas)
se trata de vida sana, ya saben...
sentirse frágil y triste y dependiente no es divertido,
morirse o no puede ser divertido.
Así es como me gustaría describirlo.
Es un trance global.
Son las increíbles excusas
que la gente da para el envejecimiento.
Sin embargo, no estoy diciendo
que esas excusas no tengan valor.
Hay algunas buenas conclusiones que sacar de aquí.
Cosas que deberíamos estar pensando, planificando
para que nada se... bueno, para que minimicemos
la agitación cuando descubramos cómo corregir el envejecimiento.
Pero todo esto es completamente absurdo,
cuando recuerdas tu sentido de la proporción.
Ya saben, son argumentos, cosas que
serían legítimas que nos preocuparan.
Pero la pregunta es, ¿son tan peligrosos...
estos riesgos de hacer algo frente al envejecimiento...
que superan la desventaja de hacer lo opuesto,
en otras palabras, dejarlo así como está ?
¿Son tan malos estos riesgos que están por encima
de condenar a 100.000 personas al día a una temprana e innecesaria muerte?
Ya saben, si no tienes un argumento que sea tan sólido,
entonces no me hagan perder el tiempo, es lo que digo.
(Risas)
Sin embargo, hay un argumento
que algunas personas creen realmente que es sólido, y es éste.
La gente se preocupa por la sobrepoblación; dicen,
"Bueno, si corregimos el envejecimiento, nadie va a morir
o al menos el número de muertos va a ser mucho más bajo,
sólo cruzando St. Giles con cuidado.
Y por consiguiente, no vamos a poder tener muchos hijos,
y los hijos son realmente muy importantes para mucha gente".
Y eso es verdad.
Y ya saben, mucha gente trata de eludir esta pregunta,
y dan respuestas como éstas.
No concuerdo con esas respuestas. Creo que básicamente no funcionan.
Creo que es verdad, que nos enfrentaremos a un dilema al respecto.
Tendremos que decidir si tenemos una baja natalidad,
o alta mortalidad.
Una alta mortalidad surgirá simplemente al rechazar estas terapias,
en favor de continuar teniendo muchos hijos.
Y, yo digo que eso está bien...
el futuro de la humanidad tiene derecho a hacer esa elección.
Lo que no está bien es que nosotros hagamos esa elección en nombre del futuro.
Si vacilamos, dudamos,
y no desarrollamos de verdad esas terapias,
entonces estamos condenando a una generación entera de personas...
que hubieran sido lo bastante jóvenes y sanas como
para beneficiarse de esas terapias pero, no será así,
ya que no las hemos desarrollado tan rápido como deberíamos...
estaremos negando a esas personas un período indefinido de vida,
y eso lo considero inmoral.
Ésta es mi respuesta a la pregunta de la sobrepoblación.
Correcto. Entonces el siguiente asunto es,
¿por qué deberíamos ser más enérgicos en esto?
Y la respuesta fundamental es que
el trance del pro-envejecimiento no es tan insensible como parece.
Es realmente una forma razonable de sobrellevar lo inevitable de envejecer.
Envejecer es horrible, pero es inevitable, asi que, ya saben,
tenemos que encontrar alguna forma para eliminarlo de nuestras mentes,
y es racional hacer algo que quisieramos hacer, hacerlo.
Como, por ejemplo, inventar esas razones ridículas
de que envejecer es algo bueno después de todo.
Pero por supuesto, que sólo funciona cuando tenemos ambos componentes.
Y tan pronto como lo inevitable se hace un poquito confuso,
y nos colocamos en el límite de hacer algo al respecto,
se convierte en parte del problema.
El trance del pro-envejecimiento es lo que nos impide alterarnos por estas cosas.
Por eso que tenemos que hablar mucho de esto...
evangelizar, incluso me atreveré a decir...
para captar la atención de la gente, y hacer que se den cuenta
que están en trance en este sentido.
Eso es todo lo que diré al respecto.
No voy a hablar de factibilidad.
Y la razón fundamental, creo, por la que sentimos que envejecer es inevitable
está unida a una definición de envejecimiento que ofrezco aquí.
Una definición muy simple.
Envejecer es un efecto secundario de estar vivo en primer lugar,
es decir, metabolismo.
Esto no es enteramente una declaración de perogrullo;
es una declaración razonable.
Envejecer es un proceso que les ocurre a objetos inanimados como automóviles,
y también nos sucede a nosotros,
a pesar de que tenemos muchos mecanismos automáticos de reparación,
esos mecanismos automáticos de reparación no son perfectos.
El metabolismo, que se define como
básicamente todo aquello que nos mantiene vivos día a día,
tiene efectos secundarios.
Esos efectos secundarios se acumulan y finalmente causan enfermedades.
Esta es una buena definición. Entonces digámoslo así :
podemos decir que, ya saben, tenemos esta cadena de acontecimientos.
Y hay, en realidad, dos enfoques,
de acuerdo con la mayoría de la gente, respecto a retrasar el envejecimiento.
Están lo que llamo el enfoque gerontológico y el enfoque geriátrico.
El geriatra intervendrá tarde en la vida,
cuando la patología se haga evidente,
y el geriatra tratará y retendrá el desgaste del tiempo.
y evitará que la acumulación de los efectos secundarios
causen la enfermedad tan pronto.
Por supuesto, es una estrategia cortoplacista, es una batalla perdida,
ya que las cosas que causan la patología
se tornan mas abundantes a medida que el tiempo pasa.
El enfoque gerontológico se ve mucho más prometedor en la superficie,
por que, ya saben, prevenir es mejor que curar.
Desgraciadamente el asunto es que no entendemos el metabolismo muy bien.
De hecho, tenemos una deplorable comprensión de cómo funcionan los organismos,
incluso de células no sabemos mucho todavía.
Hemos descubierto cosas como, por ejemplo,
la interferencia del ARN, sólo hace unos años,
y esto es un componente fundamental del funcionamiento de las células.
Básicamente, la gerontología es un buen enfoque al final,
pero no es el momento oportuno para esa perspectiva
cuando hablamos de intervención.
Entonces, ¿qué hacemos?
quiero decir que es una buena lógica, que suena muy convincente,
bastante sólida, ¿cierto?
Pero no es así.
Antes de que les diga por qué no lo es, voy a adentrarme
en lo que yo llamo etapa dos.
Sólo supongan, como les he dicho, que adquirimos...
pongamos por caso hoy...
la capacidad de conceder 30 años más de vida saludable
a personas que ya están en la mediana edad, digamos 55 años.
Voy a llamarlo sólido rejuvenecimiento humano. ¿De acuerdo?
¿Qué significa esto en realidad?
¿por cúanto tiempo las personas de diversas edades hoy en día...
o de igual forma, de diversas edades en el momento en que esas terapias lleguen
vivirían en realidad?
Para responder esa pregunta... ustedes podrían pensar que es simple,
pero no es simple.
Podemos decir, "Bueno, si son bastante jóvenes para beneficiarse de esas terapias,
entonces vivirán 30 años más".
Esa es la respuesta equivocada.
Y la razón de que sea la respuesta equivocada es el progreso.
Hay dos clases de progreso tecnológico en realidad,
para este propósito.
Hay importantes y fundamentales avances,
y hay mejoras graduales de esos avances.
Difieren mucho
en términos de previsibilidad de los plazos.
Avances fundamentales:
muy difícil de predecir cuánto tiempo se va a tardar
en llevar a cabo un avance fundamental.
Hace mucho tiempo que decidimos que volar sería entretenido,
y no fue hasta 1903 cuando averiguamos cómo hacerlo.
Después, las cosas estuvieron bastante estables y uniformes.
Creo que es una secuencia razonable de hechos que sucedieron
en el progreso de la tecnología aeronáutica.
Se puede pensar, realmente, que cada uno va
más allá de la imaginación del inventor de lo anterior, si se quiere.
Los avances graduales se deben a algo
que ya no es gradual.
Esto es lo que se ve después de un avance fundamental.
Y lo ves en toda clase de tecnologías.
Computadores, se puede ver una línea de tiempo más o menos paralela,
sucediendo por supuesto un poco más tarde.
En la atención médica, en cuanto a higiene, vacunas , antibioticos...
ya saben, el mismo plazo de tiempo.
Creo que en realidad la etapa dos, que la he llamado etapa hace un momento,
no es del todo una etapa.
De hecho, las personas que son lo bastante jóvenes
como para beneficiarse de estas primeras terapias
que ofrecen esta moderada extensión de vida,
aunque esas personas ya estén en la mediana edad cuando las terapias lleguen,
estarán como en la cúspide.
La mayoría sobrevivirán lo suficiente para recibir tratamientos mejorados
que les darán 30 o tal vez 50 años más.
En otras palabras, ellos jugarán con ventaja.
Las terapias mejorarán tan rápido que
las restantes imperfecciones nos están alcanzando.
Esto es un punto muy importante a considerar.
Porque, ya saben, la mayoría de la gente cuando oye
que pronostico que un gran número de gente va a vivir 1.000 años o más,
piensan que estoy diciendo que vamos a inventar terapias en las próximas décadas
qur van a eliminar completamente el envejecimiento
que esas terapias nos permitirán vivir 1.000 años o más.
No estoy diciendo eso.
Estoy diciendo que con la tasa de mejoramiento de esas terapias
bastará.
Nunca serán perfectas, pero seremos capaces de dar respuesta
a las enfermedades de las que mueren los de 200 años de edad, antes de tenerlos.
Y lo mismo para los que alcancen 300... y 400 etc.
Decidí darle a esto un nombre corto,
es " velocidad de escape a la longevidad".
(Risas)
Bueno, parece que llegamos a lo importante.
Estos trayectos de aquí son básicamente cómo esperamos que viva la gente,
en términos de expectativa de vida,
según los indicadores que marcan su salud,
y los años que tenían en el momento que llegan estas terapias.
Si usted ya tiene 100 años, o incluso si tiene 80...
y un promedio de 80 años de edad,
probablemente no podemos hacer mucho por usted con estas terapias,
porque usted está a puertas de la muerte
para que las terapias iniciales sean lo suficientemente buenas para usted.
Usted no podrá resistirlas.
Pero si usted tiene sólo 50 años , entonces hay una posibilidad
que podría rescatarlo y, ya saben...
(Risas)
finalmente superar esto.
Y empezar a ser biológicamente más joven en un sentido significativo,
en términos de juventud, física y mental,
y en términos de riesgo de muerte por causas relacionadas con el envejecimiento.
Y por supuesto que, si usted es un poco más joven,
nunca va a estar
tan frágil como para morir por causas relacionadas con el envejecimiento...
Ésta es una conclusión a la que he llegado, que el primero que llegue a los 150 años...
no sabemos cuanto años tiene hoy esa persona,
porque no sabemos cuánto tiempo se a va tardar
en conseguir esa primera generación de terapias.
Pero independientemente de esa edad,
estoy afirmando que la primera persona que llegue a 1,000 años
dependiendo por supuesto, de las catástrofes globales...
será, probablemente sólo 10 años más joven que el primero de 150 años de edad.
Menudo pensamiento.
Vale, finalmente voy a dedicar el resto de la charla,
mis últimos siete minutos y medi, a la etapa uno.
en otras palabras, ¿cómo obtenemos esta moderada extensión de vida
que nos permitirá escapar de la velocidad?
Y para hacer esto, necesito hablar un poco de ratones.
Tengo un sólido hito en lo que se refiere al rejuvenecimiento humano.
Lo voy a llamar rejuvenecimiento sólido del ratón, no es muy original.
Y esto es lo que es.
Vamos a tomar un tramo largo de vida de un ratón,
básicamente significa que el ratón vive una media de tres años.
No les hacemos nada hasta que tengan dos años de edad.
Y entonces les hacemos un serie de cosas,
y con esas terapias, los mantenemos vivos,
de media, hasta su quinto cumpleaños.
Entonces, en otras palabras, agregamos dos años...
triplicamos su vida restante,
empezando desde el punto en que empezamos las terapias,
La pregunta entonces es, ¿qué signifcaría eso para el plazo de vida
hasta que alcancemos el hito, del que les hablé antes, para los humanos?
Lo que ahora podemos, como he explicado,
de forma similar, llamar sólido rejuvenecimiento humano, o velocidad de escape a la longevidad.
En segundo lugar, ¿qué significa desde el punto de vista del público
el tiempo que vamos a tardar en alcanzar esas cosas,
empezando desde el tiempo que tomamos a los ratones?
Y en tercer lugar, la pregunta es ¿qué le hará
en realidad a la gente que lo desee?
Y me parece que la primera pregunta
es enteramente un pregunta biológica,
y es extremadamente difícil de responder.
Uno tiene que ser muy especulativo,
y muchos de mis colegas dirían que no deberíamos especular,
que deberíamos guardar silencio hasta que sepamos más.
Yo digo que no tiene sentido.
Seríamos irresponsables si nos mantenemos callados sobre esto.
Necesitamos dar nuestra mejor estimación en cuanto a plazo de tiempo,
para dar al la gente un sentido de proporción
para que puedan valorar sus prioridades.
Así que yo digo que tenemos el 50 por ciento de posibilidades
de alcanzar el hito RHR ,
sólido rejuvenecimiento humano, dentro de 15 años desde el punto
que lleguemos al sólido rejuvenecimiento del ratón.
15 años a partir de lograr un ratón robusto .
La percepción del público probablemente será algo mejor.
El público tiende a subestimar lo difícil que son las cuestiones científicas.
Entonces probablemente pensarán que faltan cinco años.
Estarán equivocados, pero en realidad no importará mucho.
Y finalmente, por supuesto, creo que es justo decir
que una gran parte de la razón por la que el público es tan ambivalente respecto al envejecimiento
es el trance global del que ya les hablé, la estrategia de enfrentar el problema.
Esa será historia en este punto,
porque será imposible creer que envejecer es inevitable en humanos.
ya que ha sido aplazado muy eficazmente en los ratones.
Así que probablemente terminemos con un gran cambio de actitud en la gente,
y eso por supuesto que tiene enormes implicaciones.
Para explicarles cómo vamos a conseguir estos ratones,
voy a agregar algo a mi descripción de envejecimiento.
Voy a usar la palabra "daño"
para denotar esas cosas intermedias que son causadas por el metabolismo,
y que finalmente causan una patología.
Porque el asunto crítico de esto
es que aunque a veces solamente el daño causa una patología,
el daño mismo es causado a lo largo de la vida, empezando antes de nacer.
Pero no es parte del metabolismo mismo.
Y esto resulta ser útil.
Porque podemos redibujar nuestro diagrama original de esta forma.
Podemos decir que, básicamente, las diferencias entre la gerontología y la geriatría
es que la gerontología trata de inhibir la tasa
a la cual el metabolismo sitúa este daño.
Y voy a explicar exactamente lo que significa daño
en términos concretos y biológicos en un momento.
Y los geriatras tratan de retener el desgaste del tiempo
deteniendo el daño y convirtiéndolo en patología.
Y la razón de que sea una batalla perdida
es porque el daño continúa acumulándose.
Entonces, hay un tercer enfoque, si lo vemos de esta forma.
Lo podemos llamar el enfoque de la ingeniería.
y afirmo que el enfoque de la ingeniería está dentro del límite.
El enfoque de la ingeniería no interviene en ningún proceso.
No interviene en este proceso, o en éste.
Y eso es bueno porque significa que no es una batalla perdida,
y es algo que está dentro del límite de poder hacerlo,
porque no implica mejorar en la evolución.
El enfoque de la ingeniería simplemente dice,
"Vamos a reparar periódicamente todas estas clases de daños...
no necesariamente repararlos todos, pero sí bastantes,
para así mantener el nivel de daño bajo el límite
que debe existir, que hace que sea patógeno."
Sabemos que este límite existe.
porque no tenemos enfermedades relacionadas con la edad hasta que estamos en la mediana edad,
aunque el daño se haya acumulado desde antes que naciéramos.
¿Por qué digo que estamos en el límite? Bueno, porque claramente es así.
Lo importante de esta diapositiva está en la parte de abajo.
Si tratamos de decir que parte del metabolismo es importante para el envejecimiento,
estaremos aquí toda la noche, porque básicamente todo el metabolismo
es importante para envejecer de uno forma u otra.
Esta lista es sólo como ilustración, está incompleta.
La lista de la derecha también está incompleta.
Es una lista de tipos de patología que se relacionan con la edad,
y es una lista incompleta.
Pero me gustaría afirmarles que esta lista del medio está completa,
esta es la lista de indicadores que se califican como daño,
efectos secundarios del metabolismo que al final causan patología,
o que podrían causar patología,
Y hay sólo siete de ellos.
Son categorías de cosas, por supuesto, pero son sólo siete.
Pérdida de células, mutaciónes de cromosomas, mutaciones en la mitocondria etc.
Lo primero, me gustaría darles un argumento del por qué esta lista está completa.
Por supuesto uno puede hacer un argumento biológico.
Uno puede decir, OK, ¿de qué estamos hechos?
Estamos hechos de células y materia entre las células.
¿en qué se puede acumular el daño?
La respuesta es, moléculas de larga vida,
porque si una molécula de corta vida sufre daños, y la molécula es destruida...
como por una proteína que es destruida por proteólisis...el daño desaparece también.
Tiene que ser moléculas de larga vida.
Así, estas siete cosas estuvieron bajo discusión en gerontología hace ya un tiempo
y es muy buena noticia, porque significa que,
hemos avanzado mucho en estos 20 años,
el hecho de que no hayamos ampliado esta lista
es una buen indicio de que no hay que hacer ninguna ampliación.
Sin embargo, es aún mejor; sabemos realmente cómo corregirlos
en los ratones, en principio... y cuando digo en principio es,
que probablemente podamos en realidad implementar estas correcciones dentro de una década.
Algunas de ellas están parcialmente implementadas, las de arriba.
No tengo tiempo para comentarlas, pero
mi conclusión es que, si podemos conseguir un adecuado financiamiento,
entonces podremos desarrollar sólido rejuvenecimiento de la materia en sólo 10 años,
pero tenemos que tomárnoslo en serio.
Tenemos que empezar a intentarlo de verdad.
Por supuesto, en la audiencia hay algunos biólogos,
y quiero darles algunas respuestas a algunas de las preguntas que pudieran tener.
Puede que no les haya gustado esta charla,
pero fundamentalmente tienen que ir y leer todo esto.
He publicado mucho a respecto;
Cito el trabajo experimental en el cual se basa mi optimismo,
y que contiene mucha información.
El detalle que me hace confiar
en el plazo de tiempo bastante agresivo que pronostico aquí.
Asi si ustedes piensan que no tengo razón,
sería mejor que fueran a investigar por qué creen que no la tengo.
Y por supuesto lo más importante es que no deberían confiar en la gente
que se llamen gerontologistas porque,
como con cualquier desviación extrema de un pensamiento dentro de un área particular,
se espera que en la corriente principal la gente sea un poco resistente
y no se lo tome realmente en serio.
Asi que, ya lo saben, tienen que hacer los deberes,
para comprender si esto es verdad.
y terminaremos con un par de cosas.
Una cosa es, ya saben, van a oir a una persona en la próxima sesión
que dijo hace tiempo que podía secuenciar el genoma humano inmediatamente,
y todos dijeron :"Bueno, es obviamente imposible"
Y ya saben lo que ocurrió.
Entonces esto sí ocurre.
Tenemos varias estrategias... Está el Premio Ratón Methuselah,
que básicamente es un incentivo para innovar,
y hacer lo que crees que va a funcionar,
y obtienes dinero si ganas.
Hay una propuesta que en realidad planteó un instituto.
Esto va a requerir mucho dinero.
Lo que quiero decir es ¿cuánto tiempo se tarda en gastar eso en la guerra en Irak?
No mucho tiempo. OK.
(Risas)
Tiene que ser filantrópico, porque las ganancias distraen la biotecnología,
pero creo que básicamente hay un 90 por ciento de posibilidades de éxito.
Y creo que sabemos cómo hacerlo, y me detendré ahí.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: OK. No sé si van a haber algunas preguntas
pero pensé que le daría oportunidad a la gente.
Audiencia: Ya que has estado hablando acerca del envejecimiento y tratar de derrotarlo,
¿por qué tu mismo aparentas ser un hombre mayor?
(Risas)
AG: Porque soy un hombre mayor. Tengo en realidad 158 años.
(Aplausos)
Audiencia: Algunas especies en este planeta han evolucionado con sistemas inmunes,
combatiendo todas las enfermedades de tal modo que esos individuos viven lo suficiente para procrear.
Sin embargo, hasta donde yo sé, todas las especies han evolucionado en realidad para morir,
entonces cuando las células se dividen, la telomerasa se acorta y eventualmente la especie muere.
Entonces, ¿por qué la evolución parece haber seleccionado en contra de la inmortalidad,
cuando es tan ventajoso, o es la evolución algo incompleto?
AG: Brillante. Gracias por hacer una pregunta que
puedo responder con una respuesta no controvertida.
Voy a darle la verdadera respuesta mayoritaria a su pregunta,
con la cual concuerdo.
Y es, no, envejecer no es un producto de la selección;
la evolución es simplemente un producto de negligencia evolutiva.
En otras palabras, envejecemos porque es tarea difícil no hacerlo;
se necesita más disposición genética, más sofisticación en sus genes
para envejecer más lentamente,
y eso sigue siendo cierto por más que lo rechace.
Asi que, hasta el punto de que no importa la evolución,
no importa si los genes son transmitidos por los individuos,
que viven mucho tiempo o por procreación,
hay una cierta variación en eso,
que es por lo que diferentes especies tienen diferente duración de vida,
pero por eso no hay especies inmortales.
CA: ¿No importan los genes pero nosotros sí?
AG : Así es.
Audiencia: Hola. Leí en alguna parte que en los últimos 20 años,
el promedio de vida de prácticamente cualquier persona del planeta ha crecido en 10 años.
Si proyecto eso, me haría pensar
que viviré hasta los 120 si no tengo un accidente con mi moto.
¿significa eso que yo soy uno de los sujetos que va llegar a 1000 años?
AG: Si pierdes un poco de peso.
(Risas)
Sus números son un poco exagerados.
Las cifras estándares son de duración de vida
que ha ido aumentando entre uno o dos años por década.
Asi es que, no es tan bueno como piensa... o podría esperar.
Pero yo intento subir a un año por año tan pronto como sea posible.
Audiencia: Me han dicho que muchas de las células del cerebro que tenemos los adultos
están en realidad en el embrión humano,
y que las células del cerebro duran 80 años o más.
De ser eso verdad,
biológicamente ¿hay implicaciones en el mundo del rejuvenecimiento?
¿Si hay células en mi cuerpo que viven 80 años,
frente a un periodo normal, ya saben, un par de meses?
AG: Hay ciertamente implicaciones técnicas.
Básicamente lo que necesitamos hacer es reemplazar células
en esas pocas áreas del cerebro que pierden células a una tasa respetable,
especialmente neuronas, pero no queremos reemplazarlas
más rápido... o no tan rápido de todas maneras,
porque reemplazarlas muy rápido degradaría la función cognitiva.
Lo que he dicho hace un rato sobre la existencia de especies que no envejecen
fue un poco una simplificación excesiva.
Hay especies que no envejecen, Hydra por ejemplo,
pero lo logran no teniendo un sistema nervioso...
y no teniendo ningún tejido que dependa para su funcionamiento
de células de muy larga vida.